bonsoir une épée magnoni merci d'être
avec nous on viens de l'entendre
l'instant l'espagne qui pourrait rouvrir
mardi prochain le pays au voyageur
voyageur brésilien et sud africain
faut-il s'inquiéter de ce type
d'information nous agiter le chiffon
rouge des variants bonsoir stéphanie de
mu rue eh bien c'est vrai que ça ne sera
pas pour rassurer les touristes de
savoir qu'en quittant leur territoire
national ils vont partir en vacances
dans un pays effectivement qui a décidé
d'ouvrir la porte à des voyageurs en
provenance de zone où circule le variant
indiens ou brésiliens
évidemment on imagine que le
gouvernement l'a fait pour des raisons
évidentes d'économie puisque le tourisme
voilà a beaucoup souffert ces derniers
mois évidemment il n'empêche
est ce que c'est le genre de choses qui
peuvent faire repartir l'épidémie créer
des clusters selon le médecin que vous
êtes
oui c'est plus évident c'est d'ailleurs
assez étonnant l'espagne est toujours
innovante dans ses décisions tout en
cours tout au long de cette crise et
c'est vrai que finalement cette cette
décision de réouvrir le pays en
direction de pays où circule le variant
indien et le variole effectivement
brésilien est véritablement
effectivement une prise de risque pour
réamorcer une nouvelle nouvelle épidémie
sur le territoire espagnol
ça veut dire aussi que si l'espagne
ouvre ces personnes pourront passer dans
toute l'europe puisque actuellement les
les frontières sont assez poreuse entre
les pays c'est mettre en danger
potentiellement pour toute l'union
écoutez je pense que votre analyse
stéphanie est parfaitement objective et
c'est vrai qu'on on al'impression
finalement de revivre enfin en tout cas
de se retrouver dans le même scénario
qu'en 2020 il faut se rappeler que au
coeur de l'été 2020 ce qui avait nourri
effectivement un rebond considérable
dans toute l'europe de l'épidémie
lukowich étaient partis d'espagne 15% de
la population qui a reçu les deux doses
en espagne on est encore loin de
l'imiter collectif comment ça se passe
sur le plan de la vaccination chez vous
est ce qu'on voit une une accélération
de la cadence comme ici en france nous
allons très clairement l'espagne reste
sur le même niveau de progression de la
vaccination et c'est vrai que vu
d'espagne on a l'impression d'assister à
une véritable accélération de la
vaccination en france
c'est vrai qu'il ya l'épidémie quand
même qui poursuit sa décrue qu'on peut
assister aussi on va était si on va
essayer d'être chimiste au même
phénomène que l'année dernière une
grande accalmie pendant l'été et en
revanche peut-être une recrudescence en
octobre mais là il y aura eu peut-être
le vaccin qui va nous sauver
oui c'est vrai de toute façon chaque
année un scénario inédit
alors vous avez raison pour des raisons
qu'on explique papa pas clairement
scientifiquement l'été avec une fenêtre
favorable en termes de diminution
effectivement propagation des virus
donc effectivement on peut parier sur un
été qui seraient plutôt favorables pour
effectivement l'évolution de l'épidémie
et effectivement il y aura une heure de
vérité en septembre le rapport au degré
d'immunisation de la population par
rapport au degré d'avancé de la
vaccination sur effectivement la fin du
cauchemar où la reprise éventuellement
d'une épidémie avec pourquoi pas de
nouveaux variants pourquoi pas d'autres
options mais évidemment tout le monde
espère que cette fois on s'achemine vers
la fin
du cauchemar la france et l'espagne qui
n'ont manifestement pas les mêmes
mesures de déconfinement le couvre-feu
vous est passé à minuit il ya déjà deux
semaines
est ce que vous vous voyez vous une
incidence des cas qui augmenterait en
tant que médecin ou ont finalement
aucune incidence par rapport à ce qu'on
veut c'est vrai qu'on assiste ici un
vrai retour à la vie normale en espagne
et d'ailleurs il y à un véritable
enthousiasme dans la population de
retrouver effectivement accès à toutes
les activités qui parfois ont été
vraiment affecté
maintenant depuis deux ans et c'est vrai
que on a envie de citer la phrase de
stendhal qui disent que ce que j'aime
dans le voyage c'est l'étonnement du
retour est bien ici ce qu'on aime dans
le déconfinement c'est le l'étonnement
du retour à la vie normale pour autant
effectivement depuis quelques jours on
peut voir réapparaître en tout cas au
niveau de mon activité je vois
clairement réapparaître des réfections
coville beaucoup de réinfection sépare
assurances comme vous dites il se
reproduit exactement ce qu'on voit
chaque fois c'est à dire que chaque fois
qu'on a effectivement une augmentation
importante des des commentaires audio du
relâchement des mesures barrières
immédiatement
on revoit à paraître effectivement des
gains positifs à qu'ovide et là c'est ce
qui se passe depuis trois jours bon
merci en tout cas d'avoir témoigné nous
avoir apporté votre témoignage depuis
l'espagne alors que les autorités
sanitaires d'ailleurs songe même à
assouplir les mesures concernant le port
du masque à l'extérieur donc c'est pas
vraiment rassurant merci philippe
emmanuelli d'avoir été avec nous